There will be spoilers in this video so make
sure you’ve seen Unbreakable, Split and
Glass before watching.
If you want to hear my theory about the meaning
behind the clover tattoos, then stick around
to the end of this video.
Glass begins with four cheerleaders abducted
by Hedwig and David Dunn, who is starting
to become known as the Overseer, shifting
his focus from petty criminals to The Horde.
We first see him take out these kids who are
filming themselves Superman punching a random
guy on the street to try to go viral.
These low criminals are pretending to be superheroes
online, which provides a stark contrast with
the ending of Glass where real superheroes
leak on social media.
David now has his own security company, Dunn
Home Security.
Elijah says in Unbreakable says that David
works in security for a reason, because he’s
a born protector, so it makes sense that he
gets his own company.
“You could have been a tax accountant.
You could have owned your own gym.
You could have opened a chain of restaurants.
You could have done one of 10,000 things,
but in the end you chose to protect people.
You made that decision, and I find that very,
very interesting.”
The next day at work, M Night Shyamalan, the
director of the trilogy, makes his cameo appearance,
and it answers one of the questions I had
going into the movie.
He mentions that he’s getting more cameras
because one of his tenants was killed off-site.
He’s talking about Dr. Fletcher, so it seems
that Jai, from Split wasn’t just an IT guy
helping Dr. Fletcher review security footage,
but actually her landlord.
And probably also her landlord.
“You can’t use your thumbs to spin the
wheel dumb-***es.”
Jai goes on to see David and he recognises
him as the security guard from those years
ago, and tells him he used to hang out with
the shady types at the stadium, but he turned
his life around.
This confirms that Stadium Drug Dealer and
Jai are in fact the same character, but this
is more than just a fun little director’s
cameo, it shows the effect that David had
cleaning up the crime around his city; he
actually had a positive impact on the community
and helped turn shady people into functioning
members of society.
David goes out again to look for The Horde
with Joseph giving him tips via headphones
and GPS tracker.
Not only is this a common superhero trope,
but it’s also a concept that Shyamalan used
in his 2013 film After Earth, although in
that movie, the roles were reversed and it
was the father giving advice to his son.
After David bumps into Hedwig on the street,
he heads toward the brick factory to look
for the girls, and the word Allies is written
in graffiti on a window in the background,
a foreshadowing the teaming up of Elijah and
The Horde.
“That sounds like the bad guys teaming up."
In the Unbreakable Things You Missed, I discussed
how upside-down camera composition was used
to foreshadow bad things happening, and the
trend seems to continue in Glass.
When David first has the confrontation with
The Beast, we see the Beast’s point of view
as he crawls along the ceiling towards David
and the rescued cheerleaders.
Like many supervillains, The Beast has a signature
move, which is, fittingly, a giant bear hug.
This is the same attack he used on Dr. Fletcher
during Split, on David during the factory
fight and the orderly when he and Mr. Glass
are escaping.
Throughout the series, broken glass is used
as a metaphor of the well being of the characters,
so when David and The Beast's battle sends
them out of the factory through a shattering
glass window it spells the beginning of the
end for them, because it leads to their capture
and placement in Raven Hill Memorial.
Once we arrive at that institution, there
is huge clue about the final twist of the
movie.
As they are placed in their rooms, we are
shown the point of view of the cameras placed
around the institution.
The entire movie, these security camera shots
are constantly being shown, the final twist
is dangled in front of us all along.
The characters are introduced to their new
psychiatrist, Dr. Ellie Staple.
At the end of the movie, we find out that
Dr. Staple is part of the ancient organization
created to suppress superheroes from the public.
She tells Mr. Glass that she they don’t
take sides, she’s not good or evil, she
essentially falls in the middle.
In a literal comic book there are staples
placed in the middle crease to hold everything
together.
Her name represents her neutrality.
Casey gets word of The Beast’s capture when
she’s pulled aside at school, and we also
see that she attended the same school as Joseph
Dunn.
I’m honestly not entirely sure what the
point of that was outside of furthering the
idea that everything is connected in a comic
book story, much like how David and Clarence
W Crumb were on the same train.
Which, as a quick side note, Clarence’s
name continues the theme of alliteration in
the first two movies with characters like
David Dunn, Casey Cooke, Kevin Crumb, and
now Clarence Crumb.
There’s also a character that I noticed
in the IMDb credits called Scarlet Shields…
I honestly have no idea who that even is.
I’m assuming she’s a minor character,
but basically every other minor character
has a name like Hospital Patient or Cheerleading
Girl #4.
I honestly have no idea who this is supposed
to be.
Maybe she was given a name just to throw off
people trying to look up information online
before the movie came out, or maybe she’s
given a name because she has an actual name
tag somewhere in the movie.
Let me know your findings on that in the comments.
David’s son Joseph meets with Dr. Staple
to try to convince her to let David go free.
When he is unsuccessful, the camera tilts
down into an upside-down position again to
watch Joseph leave the facility.
Just as Joseph saw the original train crash
footage upside-down on the couch in Unbreakable,
this camera movement in Glass also represents
impending disaster.
Speaking of Unbreakable, when I saw the deleted
scene of David coming into a young Joseph’s
room, I was completely blown away by it, because
somehow I had no idea that these deleted scenes
from the first film existed, and this one
really works well considering the themes of
Glass.
Let’s roll it.
“I’m not scared.”
“That’s great.”
“You know why?
I know now.”
“Know what?”
“Your secret identity.”
So Joseph felt uneasy about the fact that
his father has these incredible abilities
that can’t be explained, but finds comfort
in knowing he has someone to protect him.
This helps explain why it was so important
for Mr. Glass to outsmart the black clover
society and broadcast the existence of superheroes
out to the world.
Next, Casey is given the opportunity to meet
with The Horde, and discovers that her touch
can bring Kevin forward into the light.
My theory as to why Casey has this ability
relates to the fact that the additional identities
were created by Kevin’s brain as a coping
mechanism for the abuse dished out by his
mother.
It’s stated in Split that the Horde exists
to protect Kevin,
“Are you in charge?”
“Yeah, we’ve taken charge.
We’re the only ones that can protect Kevin.”
“We’re all here to protect Kevin.”
“He’s very weak.”
So naturally, the way to bring down these
protections is with love and kindness.
Casey is the only one who’s capable of this
because she too has been abused by her Uncle,
so she knows what kind of gentle hand is needed
to undo the damage.
When Casey leaves the institution after that,
she puts on the jacket given to her by the
man working at the Philadelphia Zoo who escorts
her out of danger at the end of Split.
My guess is that she still wears that jacket
as a reminder of how she stood up to The Beast
-- something that also gave her the strength
to stand up to her Uncle, and just to be a
stronger, braver person overall.
In the final examination scene, Dr. Staple
tries to convince Mr. Glass, The Horde and
The Overseer that they don’t actually have
super powers by giving rational explanations
for everything that has happened and telling
them they will remain institutionalized for
the rest of their lives if they are unable
to overcome their “disorder”.
In a way, she is actually telling the truth
-- although we don’t know it yet, the black
clover society was planning to kill them if
Dr. Staple didn’t successfully convince
them they are ordinary in the three day timespan.
But I’ll get back to the black clover society
later in this video.
Dr. Staple tells David he has symptoms of
the supposed superhero disorder, but lacks
some kind of anchoring incident that made
him realize that he is a superhero, which
is funny because the “anchoring incident”
he thinks of is literally him drowning like
an anchor.
One of the main talking points that Dr. Staple
uses to try to convince them that they are
ordinary, is that if superheroes do exist,
why would there only be the three of them?
This is Dr. Staple counting on the fact that
her black clover society will always be successful
in suppressing any supers from the public
eye.
David and Patricia appear to have their faith
in their own powers shaken.
Elijah, doesn’t respond, because he’s
pretending to be a vegetable, but he knows
that Dr. Staple is lying to them.
All the talk of comic books sends Casey to
the comic-book store to do some of her own
research, and the store is owned by none other
than the comic book store clerk from Unbreakable.
It seems that his suspicious of pervs in back
of the store hasn’t changed either, when
he yells to Joseph, “you better not be one
of those Hello Kitty pervs.”
“You better not be jacking off to the Japanese
comics I swear to God.”
--
Just as the mirror reflection shots are used
to introduce villains in Unbreakable and Split,
similar shots are used in Glass to show that
something is not right.
David sits on floor of his cell and his reflection
is distorted by the curved wall.
Across the way, The Horde is seen in a distorted
reflection through a curved mirror.
It is shortly after this that we discover
Elijah was faking his sedation and has the
ability to sneak out of his room and he discovers
the magazine advertising the opening of Osaka
Tower.
Just as the previous movies had subtle references
to The Fantastic Four and Teen Titans, the
headline of this article calls Osaka Tower
a true MARVEL.
Elijah tells The Beast that his plan is to
attack the tower on its opening date, December
7th, which is Pearl Harbor Day another major
American disaster.
More importantly, that’s also my birthday,
so put that down in your calendar right now.
Right now.
Then we get a glimpse into Elijah’s past,
when he sneaks onto a carnival ride and tries
to protect himself using stuffed animals.
This is another deleted scene, but again,
it works really well here because The Beast
ends protecting him from the orderlies and
the police as they break out of the hospital,
so it’s kind of as if he’s been protected
by animals every step of the way.
It’s also interesting to note that his plan
on the carnival ride backfires, and he ends
up breaking his shoulder, just as The Beast
turns on him at the end of Glass and breaks
his shoulder, an injury he would never overcome.
After Elijah discovers the powers of The Beast,
he formulates his plan to have The Beast battle
David in front of the world.
I think it’s important to note that it was
never Mr. Glass’s real intention to go to
the tower, all he really needed to do was
convince The Beast to break them out so he
could stream it using the cameras.
Can we copystrike Mr Glass's latest video?
And for anyone who felt that David Dunn’s
part in all of this was a little underwhelming,
let’s not forget that it was most likely
Dunn’s security company who provided all
the cameras to the institution in the first
place.
Part of Elijah’s plan was to change out
the lens of the machine used for his surgery,
then get himself caught lollygagging around
on camera so that the doctor moves up the
date of his operation.
This is important because it allows the orderly,
Daryl, to let his guard down around Elijah,
giving him the opportunity to slit his throat
with the broken shard of glass.
And just as Elijah’s broken glass cane represented
his injuries in Unbreakable, the broken picture
frames foreshadow his eventual demise in Glass.
All three characters have their “broken
glass moment”.
At the end of the second act there are a couple
more clever uses of shots that use mirror
reflections to tell us something.
The first is Dr. Staple getting out of her
car and heading into Raven Hill Memorial,
which we see through her side mirror.
These mirrors always come with a disclaimer:
objects in mirror are closer than they appear.
Well, Dr. Staple is not just a psychiatrist
as she appears to be, because she’s actually
part of this secret organization.
Our earlier mirror shots of David and The
Horde are distorted by curved mirrors, but
when Elijah finally meets The Beast, he first
sees the transformation through the reflection
of a glass cabinet.
There’s no distortion here, which tells
us that things are going to be essentially
as they should be with the impending clash
of good vs. evil.
Then Dr. Staple realizes that Elijah has broken
out, she sees the news report on TV about
the opening of Osaka Tower, and thinks Mr.
Glass is going to sabotage it.
Also, the reporter is the same guy who reports
on the missing girls in Split, and on the
news ticker at the bottom, there is a report
about cryptocurrency.
Krypton is the name of Superman’s home planet,
and Superman is referenced several times throughout
Glass.
Shortly after, the final battle begins, and
Dr. Staple curiously tells someone to make
sure to keep patients and staff away from
the south side windows.
This is because she knows that David, Elijah
and Kevin’s powers are real, and it’s
her duty to make sure nobody finds out about
them.
So that brings us back to this whole black
clover society.
Who are they?
Where did they come from?
Why do they have these matching tattoos?
And what do they have to do with Split and
Unbreakable?
All of the answers to all of these questions are
coming up.
At the end of the confrontation, a mysterious
group of SWAT members all sharing a wrist
tattoo of black three leaf clover show up
to kill David and The Beast.
Dr. Staple is revealed to be a part of this
society.
She explains that they are a group that has
been around for 10,000 years to keep superheroes
out of the public eye, because it’s not
fair to the rest of society to have Gods walking
among us.
Dr. Staple’s mission the entire time was
to get them to believe that their powers weren’t
real so they can go on living ordinary lives.
She was given the three days to do so, but
if she failed, the alternative was some kind
of brain surgery, or death.
In Split, we are shown how the organization’s
manipulation of society has worked.
Society sees The Horde’s dissociative identity
disorder as a problem, a mental illness that
needs to be cured.
Dr. Fletcher’s thesis to the medical community
is that maybe those with this condition are
actually extraordinarily gifted.
“Well, we look at people who have been shattered
and different as less than.
What if they are more than us?”
But Dr. Fletcher is largely rejected by her
peers, and it’s because the black clover
society has been working for 10,000 years
to condition us to see this as a mental illness.
That’s exactly what Dr. Staple does in Glass,
she rounds up three of the most extraordinary
supers in Philadelphia and tries to convince
them that something is wrong with them and
that they need treatment.
That’s why she wants Casey to get Kevin
to hold onto the light, because she is aware
of the power someone with DID is capable of.
The existence of this group also explains
a question brought up way back when Elijah
and David have their first meeting in Unbreakable.
“I believe comics are our last link to an
ancient way of passing on history.
The Egyptians drew on walls.
Countries all over the world still pass on
knowledge through pictorial forms.”
Remember when Dr. Staple is meeting with Joseph,
Casey and Elijah’s mother, and tries to
convince them that comics are nothing more
than fantasy?
She even brings up comic-book conventions
to try to invalidate them.
The only time she gets frustrated is when
they try to link their situation to what they
have seen in comic books.
The clover society is there to ensure that these
stories exist through pictures, as seemingly
fictional stories, but nothing more.
“I believe comics are a form of history
that someone somewhere felt or experienced.
Then of course those experiences and that
history got chewed up in the commercial machine,
got jazzed up, made into titillating cartoons
for the sale rack.”
In Glass, the “someone somewhere” Elijah
is referring to is his mother, Joseph and
Casey, only this time instead of distributing
comics to be chewed up in the commercial machine,
they have actual video evidence of the existence
of these powers.
Dr. Staple also mentions that when one super
appears, another is likely to appear opposite
of him, and it just leads to conflict, which
is why she feels the clover society needs
to appear to pacify them.
“If there is someone like me in the world
and I am at one end of the spectrum, couldn’t
there be someone else opposite of me at the
other end.
Someone who doesn’t get sick, who doesn’t
get hurt like the rest of us.
And he probably doesn’t even know it.”
OK, but why the black clover tattoos, that
seems kind of random?
Well maybe not.
We can look at it from the secret organization’s
perspective and from a filmmaking perspective.
First from a filmmaking perspective.
The fact that David, Elijah and The Horde’s
journey as superpowered humans ends with a
tattoo of these clovers kind of brings the
trilogy full circle.
Let’s go wayyy back to when we are introduced
to David in Unbreakable.
A woman appears asking him if he’s alone,
and she takes the spot next to him on the
train.
He notices a tattoo on her abdomen which appears
to be a rose, but we only see the bottom of
the stem because this is the very root of
David’s story.
When we see the secret society’s clover
tattoos at the very end of David’s story,
we’re seeing the top of the plant, so it's
as if we’ve come all the way around.
But then why not use a rose tattoo for the
society as well?
The clover does a better job of representing
their values.
They essentially want to purge the world of
anyone who has these rare, special powers.
A four leaf clover is considered a rare and
lucky find, much like how a superhero is a
rare incredible standout in our society.
But the black clover people don’t want that,
they want everyone to be a three leaf clover
and that’s why is was chosen as the symbol
of their organization.
Finally, there was one other minute detail
that I felt really brought the series to a
nice conclusion.
Mr. Glass famously gets his supervillain name
from the kids that made fun of his condition,
osteogenesis imperfecta.
They called me Mr. Glass.”
Elijah’s mother lives across from a playground,
we see this in a flashback during Unbreakable.
At the end of Glass, before the email comes
in from Elijah containing the footage of the
final battle, you can hear the sounds of children
playing from outside.
How fitting that the very playground that the kids
that poked fun of Elijah at, part of what put
the villain idea in his head in the first place and gave him
his awakening as a supervillain can be heard
again, just before Elijah’s mother puts
out that video to help all heroes and villains
across the world have their realization and
awakening.
When David first accepts his newfound powers
in Unbreakable, Elijah tells him to go to
where there are people, and he goes to the
train station.
That’s exactly what Mrs. Price, Joseph and
Casey do when they unveil the existence of
these comic book heroes to the world.
If you enjoyed this video, you can check out
my Things You Missed episodes on Unbreakable
and Split as well, and make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming, we both survive.